You might think about kindness
as being this quite soft, fluffy,
wishy-washy thing,
but actually, it's really fundamental
to how we connect with each other.
I think being kind is part
of the purpose of being alive.
Acts of kindness are needed in the
world, right now more than ever.
Back in 2011, I was sitting in
a café, just enjoying a breakfast,
when I looked up at a screen
and there was a double-decker bus
on fire in London.
It was terrifying.
It looked like civil war.
And there was a very negative
response to the riots
that really upset me as well.
I'd felt increasingly despairing
about what felt like the enormity
of the problems of the world.
I didn't know what I could do.
And he was overwhelmed
with gratitude,
it was disproportionate to my tiny
amount of time and money.
But I thought, I did kind of
put a smile on his face,
that sort of did make a difference.
So as I was going home,
I concocted this foolhardy notion
that I was going to try and do an
act of kindness every single day
for a stranger for a year.
It was completely life-transforming.
It's one of the big paradoxes
of kindness,
that an act of kindness that
is intended to benefit others
actually had some positive
consequences for yourself.
There are patterns of activation
in the brain
which correspond
to a boost to wellbeing.
The reward pathways in the brain
are activated
when people are performing kind acts.
Those relationships that are required
for working cooperatively
are founded upon basic
social connections.
So it's pretty fundamental
to how human beings
interact with each other.
Thank you so much,
that's really kind of you.
Oh, yes. So over the course
of the year,
it proved itself to be
utterly heart-warming,
completely terrifying,
occasionally expensive,
sometimes physically hazardous,
like when I carried some
really heavy shopping
over four miles to a lady's flat.
So it was a really,
sort of, creative journey,
that was also tiring
and incredibly inspiring.
Kindness changes the world!
I was like high every day.
Mostly it was kind of a warm glow
round your heart and also your tummy.
It just felt really good.
Human beings have a predisposition
to exhibit kindness to other people.
But they also have the possibility
of demonstrating quite significant
unkindness to other people.
The environment makes
a huge difference.
All of those stories about
kindness being weak,
we have to challenge those now.
When you think of a really
successful person
do you think of someone who's kind?
Or do you think of someone
who's out there in the limelight,
really dominant figure, a celebrity,
who's very wealthy?
What can we do to turn the narrative
of success around,
so we say that actually
being successful
does involve positive relationships
with other people.
This is one of my favourites.
Some old people dancing.
I just thought about
how elderly people
had no contact beyond
the walls of their care homes.
What started off as quite
a small localised idea
just became something way bigger
than I could ever have imagined.
It's reached over 250 schools
and over 250 care homes
and positively impacted
thousands of people.
What we witnessed during that time
was how much we yearn
to help each other.
What we have to do now is remember
the immense kindness that we were
capable of during this time.
This can't simply be a matter
of instructing people
in a given setting to be kind.
Hey, you. You need to be kind.
We need to change our environment
so that it feels normative
to be kind.
I would really like to see
businesses, schools, hospitals
all public services,
have a kindness manifesto.
So that they all ask themselves,
"Is this kind?"
So that it becomes an ordinary
part of our conversation
at every level in every
organisation, everywhere.
The biggest lesson for me
was to embrace the fact
that every single day
I can do something.
That thing might be just saying
good morning to someone.
That thing might be just smiling.
That's how we change the world.
If you carry out a good deed
to someone else
that will increase the chance of them
carrying out kind deeds
to other people.
So it kind of goes
in a circle, kindness.
The small stuff may actually
be the big stuff.
All those small things that you
figure, "Well, they're not important,
just people being nice
to each other."
Maybe that's the most important
thing for creating an environment
which actually enables
people to feel good
and to be able to work together
and to be able to take on
some really big challenges.
In the same way that a beach is
filled with a billion grains of sand,
there's this sort
of beautiful humility
in saying, "I can, at every single
moment, at any point of any day,
contribute to making the world
a better place."